hello there Marvel Spider-Man 2 is one
of the games of the year and every great
game deserves great glitches from a
Naruto running Spider-Man to Venom
honoring black panthers wakanda forever
salute oh and we also find the
whereabouts of Rhino and let's visit the
Statue of Liberty 2 here are 20 glitches
and out of bound secrets in Spider-Man 2
let's start with the bicycle which can
be found in the open world at this
location just north of the bridge in
Queens hop on with Miles or Peter to
cruise around the City freely it will
despawn after traveling too far which
confirms it's not supposed to be here
but it's pretty cool all the same to see
the web heads having free time okay now
let's completely break that bike head
towards the nearest Subway entrance and
ride down it doing this will cause your
character to glitch and return above
ground while the bike stays underground
and now your arms are a bit different
running can make you look like you
should be in an anime or even worse this
will happen Spider-Man can still emote
and fight in this this mode and don't
worry about reloading your save the
glitch fixes itself soon after I next
wanted to know if Venom could ride that
bike but first we need to get him free
from his mission When You Reach this
part in the story look towards scaling a
building which can be quite difficult as
most buildings can be glitched through
and then you're trapped inside like this
I suggest using this building here and
scaling all the way up to the top and
now we have another issue there is an
automatic invisible barrier which forces
Venom back into the bounds of the
mission to get past this we just need a
bit of momentum so run between the two
barrier points up here until Venom is
free jump down to start free roaming the
first thing I tried is to see if the big
man can swim and yes no I honestly can't
tell okay back over to that bicycle and
check it out Venom can indeed ride the
bike it's a mess but mechanically he is
riding it Venom is a real New Yorker it
definitely is broken but it's something
everyone should see at least once a
common glitch in the game is thanks to
the sheer amount of Suits we have on
offer by changing between them quick
enough a locked suit can be accidentally
triggered but instead of wearing that
suit we look like this a cube of tofu
this glitch will definitely crash your
game if done for too long but check it
out spider cube in action beautiful
wings and combat but the real highlight
is carrying an NPC let's start a
petition today for spider Cube to be in
the next spider first movie The Cube
glitch can go further when transitioning
to scenes where Peter and miles are in
their civilian clothing like this check
it out miles becomes a floating head we
know he technically can become
transparent so let's call this a super
ability and his family don't seem to
mind at all I'm sure you visited the
wander Embassy with Miles and given a
tribute to black panther a very touching
moment which I'm now going to break for
you instead of walking to that
interaction spot on foot instead crawl
up the wall and onto the shelter above
now you're upside down hit the emote
again upside down Wanda forever as it's
Spider-Man it actually looks like it's
intended but sadly your game is now
completely glitched and getting down
from here is tougher than it looks and
worse still the game becomes unplayable
but it's strangely captivating too I
think you know what I had to do next I
had to take Venom down there to see if
he would show respect to the wakandan
Embassy on bosan way and speaking of
bosan way the tribute to Chadwick bosan
the street signs cannot be broken well
they can but the sign stays in one piece
now that is real respect okay the moment
you've been waiting for let's try the
salute it totally works Venom hits the
wakanda forever salute and it's
beautiful the next one was so unexpected
my mission was simple somehow bring
Haley up here to pay her respects to the
wakandan Embassy but little did I know
how difficult that would be getting
Haley out of bounds was remarkably easy
during her Mission there is an elevator
section and up here simply use the
toolbox to get up onto the tool bench
and then walk over the edge of the
building to Freedom huzzah then the long
slow trk to the right location began
because Haley can't jump Haley can't
Sprint Haley can't swing luckily though
Haley has the ability to throw stones at
things which I did to many of the cars
it helped pass the time immensely long
story short Haley arrived and I was
certain she'd give the crossarm salute
yet this happened instead Haley refuses
she shakes her head in actuality the
animation attempts to begin but instead
freeze is Haley in place and she can
only move her head left and right I
don't think she's deliberately
disrespecting wakanda like that whilst
we're up here anyway I also ran Haley up
to the bike to check she can ride it and
ride she can did you enjoy that Haley
nope on my travels around New York I
noticed that the buses are slightly too
wide for the roads they occupy and by
repeatedly visiting their typical
locations it's possible to trigger this
glitch a car has spawned and taken up
the same space the bus is already in
creating this technical Marvel I think
we found the original prototype
Transformer oh it's so cool a super easy
glitch to see can be found during your
time at the fairground with Harry and MJ
you'll see many seats to park your butt
on for a conversation be sure to choose
this one here and if Harry is in the
right place this will
happen Harry gets a little bit too close
and his head totally bugs out it doesn't
last long things will fix themselves
when you stand back up next on my Hit
List was the desire to visit the Statue
of Liberty in a normal game we are
automatically forced back onto the play
area so we can never get to her close up
I even tried going under the map using a
broken spot from an older Spider-Man
game to get there but nah it didn't work
I'll tell you more about that spot later
the next method is to use a train and
use it to be pushed out of the bounds of
the world the best spot to do this is on
this bridge here simply wait for a train
and keep spamming backwards in the Dodge
button to use the momentum of the train
to push you out out of bounds and that's
the hardest part done it's a simple
slide and glide all the way down to the
Statue of Liberty now making sure we
stay away from the main island and voila
we've made it to the Statue of Liberty
it should be noted that all this down
here is like a mirage there are no
Collision here so Spiderman can
literally pass through any of these
objects there are some trees though to
allow Peter or miles to get extra height
for a few sneaky selfies with the big
green girl she isn't high resolution at
all but we can visit the Statue of
Liberty in Spider-Man 2 mission
accomplished this outof bounds method
can be used to look anywhere on the map
by traveling thousands upon thousands of
meters away you'll find tiny cities and
2D Greenery that looks so amazing from
far away but look like this when close
up and for science I kept going all the
way to the end and eventually you'll be
stuck in an endless ocean and our
Spider-Man vanishes straight up gone the
next out of bound secret deserves credit
a dude on Reddit found this first I have
no idea how to say this name my golfer
Clicks in hden on the island is a secret
room with a prototype of Craven's Lair
down here we can find his throne and
behind it are the heads of four of the
Sinister Six here's how you get to see
it yourself if you want to swing over to
this location on the map and until it's
patched there is a spot where Peter and
miles will fall through it from here we
need to travel North be careful not to
swing too low on these parts or you'll
hit the death barrier you'll soon
stumble on this underground location
maneuver around to find this opening and
then Barrel straight in there crawl Ong
the pipes until you reach this location
here and here's the main issue it's a
solid wall no Spider-Man can enter this
Zone and that's where click's big brain
comes in by using the photo mode and
shimmying the camera through the tiniest
of gaps here you'll find Craven's Lair
his throne is surrounded by skulls and
his trusty low res Spear and here's the
money shot Rhino and friends have been
stuffed and turned into trophies if you
finish the game you'll know that Rhino
isn't even part of the story at all
which suggests this is either a joke
during development or a very different
storyline was planned for Alexi this
might be my favorite out of bound secret
ever finally be sure to visit the
basketball courts at Visions Academy and
throw those meatballs to duplicate them
one bounces away as the other one is
embedded in the wall that you throw it
at weird eh that's got to be patched
very soon anyway that's 20 glitches and
out of bound secrets in Marvel
Spider-Man I hope this was some use to
you hi madam you're awesome it's been a
pleasure I'll see you next time
time